episode. Maybe I'll clip this as the cold open. Listen, folks, this is all chaos, no algorithms. Feel free to skip if you are only here for the algorithm content. I don't want to hear, you know, I'm 17 minutes in and I haven't heard anything about a reduction. Listen, folks, chaos with sprinkles of information. This is all chaos. And there will be a tiny bit of information. There is lots of stuff Bryce and I need to talk about. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 275, recorded on February 26, 2006. My name is Connor. And today with my co-host, Bryce, we chat about some recent travel troubles for both of us. Oh, man, what a week.
剧集。也许我会把这段剪辑成开场白。听着，各位，这完全是一团糟，没有任何算法。如果你只是为了算法内容而来，请随意跳过。我不想听到有人说，你知道，我已经听了17分钟了，还没听到任何关于归约的内容。听着，各位，这是夹杂着一点点信息的混乱。这完全是混乱。而且只会有一点点信息。布莱斯和我有很多事情要谈。欢迎收听ADSP播客，第275集，录制于2006年2月26日。我是康纳。今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯一起，聊聊我们俩最近遇到的旅行麻烦。天哪，真是糟糕的一周。
What a week, folks. Let's dial the chaos up to 12. So you're safe now, at least. You're safe now, at least. I am safe. I think I was always safe. It was just a little, what's the word, touch and go for. So my perspective on this is that it's more important.
真是糟糕的一周，各位。让我们把混乱程度调到12级。所以你现在至少安全了。你现在至少安全了。我很安全。我想我一直都很安全。只是有点，怎么说呢，悬而未决。所以我对此的看法是，这更重要。
perhaps whether you feel safe on a trip than with the actual level of safety. I always felt safe. I mean, most listeners won't remember this, I don't think. But back in, I don't remember the year, but it was 2017-ish, there was a van attack in Toronto. And this was pre-ADSP, pre-podcast. And I think it was like 10 or 11 people. died, which I guess for America's like not a big deal, but it was the, I think, are you saying that because there's more people in America or because there's more violent crime in America? No, America has a problem with, I don't want to upset of listeners with your Second Amendment stuff, but I mean, you guys seem to have a lot of mass casualty events. The point being, it, it doesn't
比起实际的安全水平，旅行时你是否感到安全可能更重要。我一直都感到安全。我的意思是，大多数听众可能不记得了，我不认为他们会记得。但在，我不记得是哪一年了，大概是2017年左右，多伦多发生了一起货车袭击事件。那是在ADSP之前，播客之前。我想大概有10或11人死亡，我想这在美国可能不算什么大事，但这是，我想，你是说因为美国人口更多，还是因为美国暴力犯罪更多？不，美国有问题，我不想用你们的第二修正案之类的东西让听众心烦，但我的意思是，你们似乎有很多大规模伤亡事件。重点是，它，它甚至不
even like break, if you include America, you know, the top whatever. I can. can find the stats. But it was the worst or second worst attack in modern Canadian history. And if it's, if you, it's the second, the worst one was like a hundred plus years ago. So, I mean, in the last century, it was the worst one. Anyways, the point, I'm going on a digression that we don't need to go on here. The point being is I lived right on top of that. I remember my father calling me or messaging me like 10 minutes after the attack happened because he's a journalist. So in, in his newsroom, it was like coming across the wire that something near Young and Finch which was only a couple kilometers from where I lived at the time was happening.
算，如果你把美国包括在内，你知道，排在前几名。我可以找到统计数据。但这是加拿大现代史上最严重或第二严重的袭击事件。如果它是，如果你，它是第二，最严重的那次是一百多年前。所以，我的意思是，在上个世纪，这是最严重的一次。总之，重点是，我正在跑题，我们不需要在这里跑题。重点是我当时就住在事发地点上方。我记得我父亲在袭击发生后10分钟左右给我打电话或发信息，因为他是记者。所以在他所在的编辑部，消息传出说在央街和芬奇大道附近发生了什么事，离我当时住的地方只有几公里。
And I had my headphones in and I was working. And I took the headphones out and I could hear like helicopters and sirens. And I was like, oh, I guess maybe something did happen. And I walked out to my balcony and I could see, I think it was 14 emergency response vehicles, including it. Was this in your old apartment, the one that I've been to post-pandemic? No. That one was downtown that you stayed at that one time. This one was long before we had even met.
我当时戴着耳机在工作。我摘下耳机，能听到直升机和警笛声。我就想，哦，我想可能真的发生了什么事。我走到阳台上，我能看到，我想大概有14辆应急响应车辆，包括它。这是在你以前的公寓吗，就是我疫情后去过的那间？不。那间是在市中心，你那次住过。这间是在我们认识很久之前。
This was at my very first job when I was working at a company called GGI. Oh, that's right. 2017. We wouldn't have even known each other yet. Yeah, back when I was a budding programmer and mostly an actuary at the time. How many years ago was 2017? That was like a decade ago. Yeah, it was a decade ago pretty much.
这是我在GGI公司工作时的第一份工作。哦，对了。2017年。我们那时还没认识。是的，那时我还是个初出茅庐的程序员，当时大部分时间是个精算师。2017年是几年前？那大概是十年前了。是的，差不多十年前了。
Yeah. And the point being is, yeah, I look down, I see like 14 emergency response vehicles. There's an ambulance bus, which I don't think I've ever seen in my, life and I'm just like, oh damn. And so I live, you know, right where it happened. It was like a two kilometer stretch, or maybe three from Young and Finch to Young and Shepard. And in order to get to work, which is on the opposite side of the street, like 500 meters from where I live, just down the road. I had to walk all the way to Young and Shepard and like do a 180 because they had roped off or taped off and they wouldn't let you cross the road. And it was pretty wild. The point being here is that I
是的。重点是，是的，我往下看，我看到大概14辆应急响应车辆。有一辆救护车巴士，我想我这辈子都没见过，我就想，哦，该死。所以我就住在，你知道，就在事发地点。从央街和芬奇大道到央街和谢泼德大道，大概有两三公里的路程。为了去上班，公司在街道的对面，离我住的地方大概500米，就在路下。我不得不一直走到央街和谢泼德大道，然后掉头，因为他们封锁了道路，不让你过马路。这真是太疯狂了。重点是，我
basically lived right on top of a quote unquote like a domestic terror attack and there was 200 people at that company and I don't think anyone knew directly anyone that was like affected by it. One of my best friends Victor who you met at the wedding. He was literally walking down the other side of the street while the truck was, you know, ramming the sidewalk of Youngstreet. All this to say is that like it reset my perspective of, you know, safety level. levels and danger because for the next week, it's all, you know, Canadian outlets were showing. Like, there was helicopter footage of, like, both my apartment and the building that I worked in. And you could literally see, like, the corner cubicle, like, level technically on the screen of, of the TV.
基本上就住在所谓的国内恐怖袭击事件的上方，那家公司有200人，我不认为有任何人直接认识受影响的人。我最好的朋友之一维克多，你在婚礼上见过他。当卡车在央街的人行道上横冲直撞时，他正走在街道的另一边。所有这些都是为了说明，它重置了我对安全水平和危险的看法，因为在接下来的一周里，所有的加拿大媒体都在播放。就像，有直升机拍摄的画面，既有我的公寓，也有我工作的建筑。你甚至可以在电视屏幕上清楚地看到那个角落的隔间。
And things pretty much went back to normal within, quote unquote, normal, not to minimize what happened. It was a tragedy. But the day-to-day life went back to normal, like, you know, within 24 hours. And I was thinking the same thing. So everybody's probably like, what happened? Why is Connor talking about this? Or really burying the lead here. Yeah, burying the lead here, folks.
事情在24小时内基本上就恢复了正常，所谓的“正常”，并不是要淡化发生的事情。那是一场悲剧。但日常生活在24小时内就恢复了正常。我也在想同样的事情。所以大家可能都在想，发生了什么？为什么康纳在谈论这个？或者真的在卖关子。是的，在这里卖关子，各位。
I was in Mexico. And so this is probably news to a lot of our international listeners. I know it was on the news internationally, but although today I just saw, I've only listened to like 10 minutes of it, the daily episode today is of the El Mancho. I think it's the Holisco. I don't actually know the name of the cartel. It's the Holisco cartel, but it goes by. C-J-N-G or something like that.
我在墨西哥。所以这对我们很多国际听众来说可能是新闻。我知道国际新闻上有报道，但虽然今天我刚看到，我只听了大概10分钟，今天的《每日》节目是关于埃尔曼乔的。我想是哈利斯科。我其实不知道那个贩毒集团的名字。是哈利斯科贩毒集团，但它被称为CJNG之类的。
And anyways, apparently this was, I don't know, I know it was Mexico's number one most wanted person. He's the head of a cartel. I don't know if he's the most number one person wanted globally, but the Mexican military killed him. I happened to be on a extended weekend trip down to Puerto Vallarda. And the crazy thing is, folks, we weren't supposed to be in Mexico. We initially booked something to Cuba.
总之，显然这是，我不知道，我知道他是墨西哥头号通缉犯。他是贩毒集团的首领。我不知道他是否是全球头号通缉犯，但墨西哥军方杀了他。我当时正好在巴亚尔塔港进行长周末旅行。最疯狂的是，各位，我们本不应该去墨西哥的。我们最初预订了去古巴的行程。
Oh, okay. And then because Trump, invaded Venezuela. They cut off the oil supply to Cuba and then pretty quickly Air Canada and WestJet, which are the two main airlines in Canada, canceled all flights until the end of April down to Cuba because there's no oil down there. So they can send the planes down, but they probably can't bring them back. Yep. And so we were like, all right, because the reason we want to go to Cuba is it's the shortest flight and we were only going for like leaving, you know, three or four days. I took a couple days off, but we weren't going for a full week.
哦，好吧。然后因为特朗普入侵了委内瑞拉。他们切断了对古巴的石油供应，然后加拿大航空和西捷航空（加拿大两家主要航空公司）很快就取消了所有到4月底飞往古巴的航班，因为那里没有石油。所以他们可以把飞机送过去，但可能无法把它们带回来。是的。所以我们当时想，好吧，因为我们想去古巴的原因是飞行时间最短，而且我们只打算去三四天。我请了几天假，但我们不是去整整一周。
We took that once for like Puerto Rico, which is like an even shorter flight for us because we're a little bit further south. Yeah. Yeah. And so then the next thought we had is, well, what's closer? Because like we don't want to go further. And so, Shima's been to the Bahamas. I hadn't been. And so we looked into there. But because I think all the Cuba flights had been canceled, there was very little ability.
我们曾经去过一次波多黎各，那对我们来说飞行时间更短，因为我们稍微靠南一点。是的。是的。所以我们接下来的想法是，还有什么更近的地方？因为我们不想去更远的地方。所以，希玛去过巴哈马。我没去过。所以我们研究了一下那里。但因为我想所有去古巴的航班都取消了，几乎没有选择。
But we found some one place we were going to stay. And so we went to go book that. But then when we booked it, it said, this is actually like $1,600 more than what we were showing you because the prices are out of date. And that was like across the board. Yeah, everywhere we were looking at. Long story long, we finally were like, we found a place. It was more expensive than we wanted it to be. Portoviarda is a little bit further.
但我们找到了一个我们要住的地方。所以我们去预订了。但当我们预订时，它说，这实际上比我们向你展示的价格贵了1600美元，因为价格已经过时了。这在所有地方都是这样。是的，我们看的每个地方都是。长话短说，我们终于找到了一个地方。它比我们想要的要贵。巴亚尔塔港稍微远一点。
But we had just been in Cancun for our wedding or Riviera Maya for our wedding. So we didn't really want to go back there. And so we just said, you know what, screw it. We haven't been to Porta Varda. It's only for three or four days, whatever. And then we were supposed to come back on Monday. And the day before that, the Mexican military killed the cartel leader. And it's funny because we were sitting on the beach that morning.
但我们刚在坎昆举行了婚礼，或者说在里维埃拉玛雅举行了婚礼。所以我们真的不想再回那里了。所以我们只是说，你知道吗，去他的。我们还没去过巴亚尔塔港。反正只有三四天。然后我们本应在周一回来。就在那之前的一天，墨西哥军方杀死了贩毒集团首领。很有趣，因为那天早上我们正坐在海滩上。
It's a Sunday morning and usually like all of the chairs fill up pretty quickly. And I heard someone saying about like flight cancellations. And so I was like, are there, is there like a weather thing? Because I had heard that there was some bad weather. And I went and checked. Yeah, we'll get there. I went and checked and there was nothing recent. And I was like, ah, this person's lost in the sauce.
那是一个周日早上，通常所有的椅子很快就会坐满。我听到有人在谈论航班取消的事情。所以我当时想，是有天气原因吗？因为我听说有一些恶劣天气。我去查了一下。是的，我们会谈到那个。我去查了一下，最近什么都没有。我就想，啊，这个人搞不清楚状况。
And then we get to, like, lunchtime. And a big group of, like, 12 people just got up, got all their stuff and, like, left. And I was like, wow, it's our lucky day. Like, we can move closer to the beach. We've got all these options for chairs. And then when we go to get a bite to eat, we see that they're, like, taping off the beach. And we're like, what? And we asked some guy.
然后到了午餐时间。一大群人，大概12个，突然起身，拿上他们的东西就走了。我就想，哇，真是幸运的一天。我们可以搬到离海滩更近的地方。我们有这么多椅子可选。然后当我们去吃点东西时，我们看到他们封锁了海滩。我们当时想，什么？我们问了一个人。
And then he points over to the horizon. and you can see smoke coming from like the hills. And he basically says like, well, there's a bunch of like shootings and some unrest. I'm going to head back to the room because there's like messaging coming out that you need to whatever. Shelter in place. Shelter in place. Yes. That's the key.
然后他指向地平线。你可以看到烟雾从山上冒出来。他基本上说，嗯，发生了一些枪击事件和一些动乱。我要回房间了，因为有消息说你需要什么。就地避难。就地避难。是的。那是关键。
That's the words they're using. And so I'm immediately like, oh, what's going on? Because it is typically the case that when stuff goes down in Mexico, they leave the hotel and tourist destinations alone. So, like, one of the things I meant about, like, the perception of safety, we travel to some maybe not as safe parts of the world, particularly in Africa and in Middle East, but I've actually always felt safer even in unstable parts of the world like Africa than I have in some parts of the Western world.
那是他们使用的词。所以我立刻想，哦，发生了什么事？因为通常情况下，当墨西哥发生事情时，他们会避开酒店和旅游目的地。所以，就像我提到的关于安全感的一点，我们去过一些可能没那么安全的世界部分地区，特别是在非洲和中东，但我实际上一直觉得在非洲这样不稳定的地区比在西方世界的某些地方更安全。
Like, as an example, I felt safer in, like, rural parts of Ethiopia, despite there being like civil conflict and like running into what point in Ethiopia, we were, you know, out in the countryside and we were driving back. We got stopped by, you know, these guys with guns. And our tour guys like, oh, this is the local militia. They don't get along so well with the, you know, federal government. They're just checking and make sure everything's okay. But I felt safer in like that environment than I felt like in public areas in Rome where I have to worry about like pit pockets. And the reason is that it's in a lot of these places, it's sort of like there's a, there's this respect or at least fear of doing anything to tourists.
例如，我在埃塞俄比亚的农村地区感到更安全，尽管那里有内战，而且在埃塞俄比亚的某个点，我们当时在乡下，我们在开车回来。我们被那些拿着枪的人拦住了。我们的导游说，哦，这是当地民兵。他们和联邦政府相处得不太好。他们只是在检查确保一切正常。但我在那样的环境中比在罗马的公共区域感到更安全，因为在罗马我必须担心扒手。原因在于，在很多这些地方，有一种对游客的尊重，或者至少是害怕对游客做任何事。
Like in Africa, all the tourist vehicles have tourists written on it in big letters. And like, if the police stop your, your car to try to shake you down, as your turrets like, hey, look, like, I got, I got like white people in here. Like, you know, the police are just like, all right, I'll try to extort a bribe from you, you know, some other time. I'm not going to mess around with these folks. And yeah, like, it feels like usually it's like an unwritten rule that, like, the tourists are
就像在非洲，所有的旅游车辆上都用大字写着“游客”。如果警察拦住你的车试图敲诈你，你的导游会说，嘿，看，我车里有白人。警察就会说，好吧，我以后再试着勒索你吧。我不会去招惹这些人。是的，感觉就像通常有一个不成文的规定，游客在很多这些地区是豁免的，因为那是很多外国资金流入的地方，如果人们害怕去那些国家。我的意思是，这是主要原因，对吧？这是墨西哥的经济引擎，或者至少是其中之一。所以……即使你是，你知道，
exempt in a lot of these areas because, like, that's where a lot of foreign money comes in and if people are afraid to go to those countries. I mean, that's the main reason, right? It's the economic, like, engine of Mexico, or at least one of them. And so... And even even if you're, you know,
一个罪犯，那仍然是有钱进来，你可能还能分到一杯羹。好吧，我的意思是，众所周知，贩毒集团非常参与很多行业，不仅仅是毒品行业。所以很多时候当你住在度假村时，那部分收入中有一定比例是流向贩毒集团的。总之，这对各行各业的生意都不好。现在到处都是关于加拿大游客和人们重新评估他们的度假目的地、滑雪地点等的头条新闻，因为这就像希玛和我正在做的那样，是非常普遍的事情。我们想逃离冬天几天。
a criminal, that's still money coming in and you're probably getting some cut of that money. Well, I mean, it's a well-known fact that the cartels are very involved with, like, a lot of industries, not just the drug industry. So like a lot of times when you're on a resort, there's some percentage of that revenue that is going to cartels. Anyway, so it's bad for business across the board. There's all these headlines now of like Canadian tourists and people like reassessing their destination vacation and like snowboarding and where they're going because it's a very common thing like like Sheima and I were doing. We want to escape the winter for a couple days.
我们去哪儿？我想我甚至在ADSP的播客上提到过一次。我不确定我最后是否剪掉了，我说，你知道，我们其实不介意去美国，因为那里更近，而且是个短途旅行。但我们不是完全抵制。但如果我们有选择去其他地方，哪怕在美国多花一个小时，我现在也宁愿避开美国，我想，原因很明显。总之，作为一个美国人。我确实喜欢我的国家，但我们明白。我明白。
Where do we go? And I think I even mentioned on a podcast on ADSP at one point. I'm not sure if I ended up cutting that that I was like, you know, we would actually wouldn't mind going to like the States because it's closer and it's a short trip. But like we don't, you know, we're not totally boycotting. But if we have the choice of going to like, you know, some other place that's only an extra hour in America, I'd rather avoid America right now for, I think, obvious reasons. And anyway, so speaking as an American. I do like my country, but we get it. I get it.
说你正在经历一个“时刻”是很客气的说法。这有点疯狂。就像，你知道，我们因为某些原因不想去美国。你知道，也许有人参与了那件事。然后我们因为石油短缺不能去古巴。有人在那里也参与了。我真的不能责怪这个人导致了对贩毒集团的打击。就像，你知道，减少贩毒集团的参与是一件好事。
You're having a moment is generous to say that you're having a moment is a generous thing. And it's kind of wild, though. It's just like, you know, we didn't want to go to America for reasons. You know, maybe someone was involved with that. And then we couldn't go to Cuba because of an oil shortage. Someone was kind of involved there. And I can't really blame this individual for causing a crackdown on the cartel. Like, you know, having less cartel involvement's a good thing.
只是我看到一些头条新闻说，处于错误的时间和错误的地点处于顶峰。所有这些都是为了说明，我在推特上滚动浏览并观看了一些小时。画面，我不得不让我的家人放心，因为我爸爸当时只是，他说，是的，画面看起来不太好。这总是问题所在，就像，你知道，拉莫娜总是无所畏惧。就像拉莫娜，她总是说，哦，我们可以去朝鲜吗？我们可以去伊朗吗？我们可以去，插入其他地方？我说，亲爱的，你正在申请你自己的卡。你不应该去任何，理论上你可以去其中一些地方。
It's just I saw some headline that's like the, probably, of being in the wrong place at the wrong time is at a peak. And all this to say is that there was some, a couple hours of scrolling on Twitter and watching. And the footage was, I had to reassure my family because my dad was just, he was like, yeah, the footage does not look good. That's always the problem is like, you know, Ramona's like super fearless. Like Ramona, she's always like, oh, can we go to North Korea? Can we go to Iran? Can we go to like, insert other places here? And I'm like, sweetie, you're in the process of getting your own card. You should not go to any, like, you could in theory go to some of these places.
你可能不应该去这些地方。是的。是的。总之，说实话，这一切最大的头痛之处在于我多次在电话上。有一次，他们最初自动把我们的航班改到了周六。是的，这可不好，因为我们本应在周一离开。总之，我不会用航班如何被改来改去来烦听众了。
You probably should not go to these places. Yeah. Yeah. It's anyways, it was, honestly, the biggest headache of it all was that I was on the phone, you know, multiple times. And at one point, they had initially moved our, automatically moved our flight to Saturday. Yeah. Which is no, bueno, seeing as we were supposed to leave on Monday. Anyways, I won't bore the listener with how all the flights got moved around.
你得答应我一件事。你得答应我一件事，那就是下次你的航班出现奇怪的混乱情况时，你得给布莱斯打个电话。我当时在凌晨2点半打电话时，曾对希玛说，已经过了75分钟了。这位女士在对我进行煤气灯操纵。她说，没有任何航空公司有空位。我说，我正在aircanada.com上看着商务舱航班。我已经完成了流程。我正要按下，她说，哦，不，不，不，不要按购买按钮。
You got to make me a promise. You've got to make me a promise, which is that the next time that you've got, like, weird chaotic stuff going on with your flights, you got to give Bryce a ring. I literally said to Shima at one point when I was on the phone at 2.30 in the morning, and it had been like 75 minutes. And this lady was like gaslighting me. She's like, there's no tickets available on any airline. And I'm like, I'm onaircanada.com looking at business class flights. I've gone through the process. I'm about to hit the, and she's like, oh, no, no, no, don't hit the buy button.
好吧，刚刚有空位了，我说你在开玩笑吗？这一定是违法的，这一定是违法的。我知道他们正在处理成百上千甚至上千个电话，但这太疯狂了。这花了一个多小时，我当时半睡半醒，总之我告诉希玛，我希望我当时有布莱斯的风度和技能，因为我相信你肯定会说，你知道，搭乘第一班航班离开。因为我们最终去了蒙特利尔住了一晚，然后昨天才从蒙特利尔飞往多伦多。所以我们是在周四录制这个节目的。
okay something just has come available and I was like are you kidding me like it's got to be illegal it has to be illegal like I know that they're dealing with like hundreds if not thousands of phone calls but it's just wild like it took over an hour I'm like you know half asleep and anyways I told she at one point I wish I had Bryce's both demeanor and skill set at this moment because I'm sure you would have been like you know out of there on the first flight there was a because we ended up going to Montreal staying overnight And then flying from Montreal to Toronto just yesterday. So we're recording this on Thursday.
所以当我们在机场时，有一架波特航空的飞机，这是多伦多的一家小型航空公司。现在是美国航空的合作伙伴。所以我一直喜欢波特航空，因为他们有新的巴西航空工业公司飞机。是的。总之，我们在那里，我们看到波特航空直飞多伦多的航班，就在同一时间离开。我们要去蒙特利尔。
So while we were in the airport, there was a Porter Airlines, which is a smaller airline that runs out of Toronto. Now an American Airlines partner. So I've always liked Porter because they have the new Embraerer. Yeah. Anyways, we were there and we saw Porter Airlines flight direct to Toronto, like leaving at the same time. We were going to Montreal.
对于可能已经忘记的听众，我不住在蒙特利尔。我住在多伦多，所以去蒙特利尔不太理想。但我们很高兴能离开。总之，整个过程中我一直在想，布莱斯会，你知道，他会援引某种身份，你知道，我是个尊贵的客户。而我只是在那里和这位女士争论，指着说，我能看到航班。请不要，请不要对我进行煤气灯操纵。总之。
And for folks that may have forgotten, I don't live in Montreal. I live in Toronto, so going to Montreal is less ideal. But we were happy to leave. Anyways, the whole time I was thinking, like, yeah, Bryce would have, you know, he would have been invoking some status, you know, I'm a valued customer. And I'm just there arguing with this lady pointing it like, I can see a flight. Please don't, please don't gaslight me. Anyways.
当你遇到这种情况时，一般来说，如果你需要预订航班，布莱斯是个不错的人选。但特别是如果事情出了大问题，给我打电话不是个坏主意。因为我有几种方法可以更快地获得客户支持。如果是我的常旅客航空公司，那就很简单。但我们的企业旅行社也做个人预订。人们可能不会惊讶地发现我和我们企业旅行社的人关系很好。
When you have stuff like, generally speaking, if you need to like book a flight somewhere, Brace is a good person to call. But especially like if things have gone terribly wrong, not a terrible idea to call to call me up. because I have a couple of ways to, like, get access to customer support faster. If it's airlines that I have status with, it's pretty straightforward. But also, like, our corporate travel agency also, like, does personal bookings. And people may not be surprised to learn that I'm pretty good buddies with the people at our corporate travel agency.
而且，你知道，我不知道这一点。很有趣，就像，你知道，很多人，我想认为旅行社可能是一个有点过时的概念。但我实际上非常重视旅行社，因为大多数航空公司对旅行社和普通客户有不同的呼叫线路，因为旅行社打进来，他们不会乱来。他们不会变得心烦意乱并对航空公司大喊大叫。这只会是非常专业的商务沟通，他们会确切地知道他们需要什么。而且，对于很多旅行社来说，他们可以做一些事情，比如70%或80%航空公司自己能做的事情。在取消航班等情况下，当你的航班需要重新预订时，通常在那一点上，旅行社帮不上太多忙。如果是你自己预订的航班，他们可能无法提供帮助。但如果你处于航班被取消且你只是需要帮助寻找回家的选择，比如新票，我们的企业旅行社在这方面相当不错。另一件事是，如果你和旅行社合作，如果你有一张直接从航空公司购买的票，不是由旅行社管理的，或者航空公司对其进行了更改，企业旅行社可以成为那个打电话的人，
And, you know, it's – I didn't know that. It's funny that, like, you know, a lot of people, I think think of – travel agents as maybe being a little bit of an outdated, you know, concept. But I actually place great value on travel agents because most airlines have different call lines for travel agents versus, you know, regular customers because a travel agent calls in, they're not going to mess around. They're not going to get all upset and yell at the airline or whatnot. It's just going to be like, you know, very business professional, you know, they're going to know exactly what they need. And also, for a lot of travel agents can do things, like maybe like, you know, 70 or 80% of the things that the airline
然后你就不必为此感到压力了。总之，那么，你到底是什么时候到家的？你周三到家的？我的意思是，我们昨天下午2、3点左右到家的。但重要的是我们离开墨西哥是在……你在蒙特利尔机场待着吗？你住酒店了吗？是的。有一个，嗯，两者都有。有一个航站楼内的酒店，希望保险会支付，因为费用相当高。是的。是的。我不知道蒙特利尔有航站楼内的机场酒店。他们确实有非常酷的，像是在停机坪上的小巴士，带你往返飞机，我喜欢那些。我非常喜欢蒙特利尔机场。
itself could do. In the case of, like, cancellations and whatnot, when, like, your flight has to get rebooked, usually at that point, the travel agent, like, can't help that much. And if it's, like, a flight that you booked yourself, they may not be able to help. But if you're in the situation where your flight's, like, canceled and you just, like, need help, like, finding an option to get home on, like, a new ticket, like our corporate travel agents, at travel agency is pretty good for that. And the other thing is that, like, if you're working with a travel agent, and if it is something that, like, you have a ticket that you bought directly from the airline that's not managed by the travel agent, or that, like, the airlines made a change to it, the corporate travel agent can be the one to call,
我其实不认为我去过蒙特利尔机场。就机场而言，它相当不错。总之，我们安全到家了。我们是在周三5点左右离开的。是的，一个疯狂的、疯狂的故事。说实话，在周一每个人都发信息问我到底在哪里时，就像，哦，是的，我基本上在，
and then you don't have to stress out about it. Anyways, but so what, when did you actually end up getting home? You got home on Wednesday? I mean, we got home yesterday at, like, 2, 3 p.m. or something. But the important thing is we left Mexico at... Did you stay at the airport in Montreal? Did you get a hotel? Yeah. There's a in, well, both. There's an in-terminal hotel that hopefully insurance will be paying for because it's rather extensions. Yeah. Yeah. I didn't know that that Montreal had an internal airport hotel. They do have the very cool, like, little buses on the lift stand that take you to and from the planes, I like those. I like the Montreal airport very much.
有一些AI生成的视频，显示美国人在街上，直升机在上面飞，说，这太疯狂了，你知道，他们在追捕贩毒集团。不是那样的。没有美国人在录制那些东西。话虽如此，确实有很多车辆在燃烧。我想这主要是为了传达一个信息。话虽如此，我确实认为有60人，有的在军方，有的在贩毒集团，被杀死了。
I don't actually think I've ever been to the Montreal airport. It was as far as an airport goes, it's pretty decent. Anyways, we got home safe and sound. We left at Wednesday, 5 o'clock or something. And yeah, a crazy, crazy story. Less honestly, I mean, at the time on Monday when everyone's messaging being like, where are you exactly? And it's like, oh, yeah, I'm pretty much in the, like,
所以这并不是一个非事件。你被酒店宰了吗？在额外住宿期间？没有，他们有一个特别费率，我假设保险也会覆盖，但特别费率不是。就像，它更便宜，但并不比你在网上找到的优惠更便宜。所以我们有一件事，我们必须为非洲之行准备这个。这是我们非洲之旅所必需的，但我认为它通常很有用，那就是我们有一个单独的国际医疗保险政策，也用于国际紧急撤离。这样如果我们要么，如果我们像，你知道，在巴布亚新几内亚的丛林里，我们中的一个人病了，我们必须被医疗后送，我们不会收到5万美元的账单。但我们也有保险，如果我们在一个糟糕的地方，他们会来把你带走。我不太清楚细节是如何运作的，但它并不贵。你购买了这个政策还是信用卡自带的？我们购买了这个政策，是单独的东西。是的。
there was a few AI slopped videos of like Americans on the streets with helicopters flying above being like, it's crazy, you know, they're going after the cartel. It wasn't like that. There were no Americans recording that stuff. That being said, there were a lot of vehicles on fire. I think it was mostly to send like a message. That being said, I do think like 60 people on, you know, some on the military, some in the cartel were killed.
明白了。我本来想说，我不知道。我不知道。我有最好的信用卡，在保险覆盖方面。我不认为它涵盖国际情况下的撤离。你知道，我过去确实非常优先考虑信用卡中的汽车保险。但在你婚礼上我和租车发生事故后，我只是要等到Waymo和自动驾驶汽车接管。我只是要尽量不再租车或开车，
So it was kind of, it wasn't a non-event. Did you get like gouged by the hotel? and stain the extra nights? No, they had a special rate, which I assume also insurance is going to cover, but the special rate's not. Like, it is cheaper, but it's not cheaper than, like, if you find some deal online. So one thing that we have is we had to get this for Africa. It was, like, required for our tour trip to Africa, but I think it's just generally
直到自动驾驶汽车接管。它就在拐角处。它就在拐角处。我想我们应该开始这一集了。也许我会把这段剪辑成开场白。听着，各位，这完全是一团糟，没有任何算法。如果你只是为了算法内容而来，请随意跳过。我不想听到有人说，你知道，我已经听了17分钟了，还没听到任何关于归约的内容。听着，各位，这是夹杂着一点点信息的混乱。这完全是混乱。而且只会有一点点信息。布莱斯和我有很多事情要谈。但等等，总之，我们到家了，安全无恙。你也遇到了旅行麻烦。还是你有一个最后一个问题，或者什么？我也遇到了旅行麻烦。我也本应在周一旅行。我不得不
useful to have, which is that we have a separate insurance policy for international medical and also for, like, international emergency evacuation. so that like if we end up, one if we're like, you know, in the jungles of Papua New Guinea and one of us gets sick and we have to be like medevaced out of there that we don't get like a $50,000 bill. But we also have like an insurance where like, you know, if we're in a bad place that they come and like take you out. I don't really know the details is how that works, but it's not that expensive. You purchase this policy or it's on a credit card? We purchase this policy, like separate thing. Yeah.
说，过去三年，我非常有福气，尽管每年乘坐50到60次航班，但我遇到的旅行中断非常非常少。部分原因，各位，只是良好的规划。我不预订连接时间超短的航班。所以我总是计划好如果我的第一班航班延误一两个小时会发生什么。而且我预订了奢侈的，纽约能够预订很多直飞航班。所以通常如果有几个小时的延误，对我来说不是什么大问题。就像我去年确实有一次取消。但今年，各位，纽约发生了两次大暴风雪。上一次是在一月，我和我母亲本应去加利福尼亚。我要去参加一个工作活动。她要
Gotcha. I was going to say, I don't know. I don't know. I've got some. I got the best credit cards. in terms of insurance coverage. I don't think it covers international situational extractions. You know, I used to really prioritize in the credit cards having the car insurance. But after the incident with me and the rental car at your wedding, I'm just going to wait until Waymo and the self-driving cars take over. I'm just going to try to not rent a car or drive a car again
同时和我一起去加利福尼亚看望一个朋友，因为我母亲年纪稍微大一点。她不喜欢独自旅行，所以她想和我一起去。她会去做她自己的事情，但只是和我坐同一班飞机。所以我们本应在周六一月飞走，暴风雪将在周日来袭，他们取消了我们当天飞往旧金山的最后一班航班，把我们改到了周二。然后周二到了，暴风雪彻底搞乱了美国航空的整个运营。所以我们周二的航班被取消了，那时我母亲说，你知道，我受够了，我要回佛罗里达。但我已经错过了一天的会议，严格来说是两天的会议，我真的需要在第三天到场。我不知道我的性格是怎么回事，我真的很讨厌取消计划。如果我制定了计划，如果我做出了承诺，我会尽一切可能去完成它。就像，如果我说我要去参加你的活动，如果有任何方法能让我去参加你的活动，我会尝试去做。所以我注意到这是在周五晚上8点。我想，我不可能，抱歉，这是周二晚上8点。我当时想，我不可能在第二天早上9点的会议前赶到加利福尼亚。然后我注意到有一班飞往洛杉矶的航班延误了三个小时，这通常会很糟糕，因为那是一班
until the self-driving cars take over. It's around the corner. It's a around the corner. I guess we should have started this episode. Maybe I'll clip this as the cold open. Listen, folks, this is all chaos, no algorithms. Feel free to skip. If you are only here for the algorithm content, I don't want to hear, you know, I'm 17 minutes in and I haven't heard anything about a reduction. Listen, folks, chaos with sprinkles of information. This is all chaos. And there will be a tiny bit of information. There is lots of stuff Bryce and I need to talk about. But wait, anyway, we're home, safe and sound. You've also had travel trouble. Or did you have one last question or what? I also had travel troubles. I also was supposed to travel on Monday. And I got to
晚上11点30分离开纽约，凌晨3点30分到达洛杉矶的航班，听起来并不好玩。但我当时想，这太棒了。如果我能赶上这班飞机，那么我就能到洛杉矶，一旦我到了洛杉矶，我会想办法的。所以我就是这么做的。我让他们把我安排在那班飞机上。我在六小时的飞行中睡觉。我在凌晨3点到达洛杉矶，我给NVIDIA企业旅行社打电话，我说，嘿，我在洛杉矶。请帮我找一班能让我到旧金山的航班。在，你知道，早上8点左右，这样我就能赶上这个会议。他们把我安排在6点30分的航班上，他们让我到了那里。但遗憾的是，我妈妈没能和我一起去旅行。但这个周一，我本应去波士顿。而且，抱歉，是的，周一我本应去波士顿。周六，他们已经取消了我的航班，因为新英格兰地区遭遇了巨大的破纪录的东北风暴。
say, the last three years, I have been very blessed where I've had very, very little travel disruptions despite taking 50 to 60 flights a year. Part of this, folks, is just good planning. I don't book flights with super short connections. So I always sort of plan for what would happen if my first flight was delayed an hour or two. And I book the luxury being a, New York being able to book a lot of direct flights. So usually if there's a couple hour delay, it's not a big deal for me. And like I did last year have maybe one cancellation. But this year, folks, there have been two big snowstorms that hit New York this year. The last one was in January and my mother and I were supposed to go to California. I was going for a work thing. She was going to
我不认为有那么糟糕。我在康涅狄格州长大。我小时候有更多的雪。但，你知道，周日大部分只是雨。但总之，他们取消了我在周一的航班，他们把我改到了周二的航班，虽然不太好，但也能用。但那时，我当时想，你知道吗，上次暴风雪来的时候，我只是想，没事的。我的航班也能飞出去。而这次我提前计划了。所以我去买了四张全额可退款的美国国铁票，一张是周一晚上的，然后三张是周二早上的，分别在周二早上5点、6点和9点。我想，你知道，也许他们会取消我重新预订的航班，他们确实取消了。
come with me at the same time to go visit a friend in California because my mother's a little bit older. She doesn't like to travel on her own, so she wanted to tag along with me. She was going to go do her own thing, but just to be in the same flight with me. So we were supposed to fly out on Saturday and January, and the snowstorm was going to hit on Sunday, and they canceled our, like, last flight of the day to San Francisco, rebooked us for Tuesday. And then Tuesday came around, and the snowstorm had just completely messed up American Airlines whole operation. And so our flight on Tuesday got canceled, at which point my mother was like, you know, I'm done, I'm going back to Florida. But I had already missed one day of meetings, technically two days of meetings, and I really needed
但不可能这四班美国国铁全部取消。好吧，到周一晚上，我的周一美国国铁取消了。然后周二我的一班火车也取消了。所以我去睡觉了，然后我早早醒来，试图，希望能赶上这班5点58分的美国国铁去波士顿。然后那班取消了。然后9点那班也取消了。然后我就想，好吧，我只是要坐，我直接坐优步去了波士顿。因为我在这儿。
to be there on the third day. And I don't know what it is about my personality where I really hate, like, canceling plans. And if I've made plans, if I've made like a commitment to do something, I will sort of try it all possible to follow through on it. It's like, if I say I'm coming to your event and there's any way for me to get to your event, I will try to do that. And so I noticed that this was like at 8 p.m. on a Friday. And I'm like, there's no way I'm going to be able to get, sorry, this was 8 p.m. on a Tuesday. I was thinking there was no way I would be able to get to California in time for this 9 a.m. meeting the next morning. Then I noticed that there's one flight to L.A. that has been delayed like three hours, which usually would be awful because then it's a flight that
为了让听众，国际听众知道，车程有多长，从你住的纽约到波士顿坐优步要多久？大概三个小时，三个半小时。但重点是这个。重点是这个。它并没有比火车票贵多少，因为火车票的价格太疯狂了，好几百美元，而且火车要花四个小时。火车比开车慢。火车比开车慢。火车比飞行慢。而且快车，你知道，他们刚刚宣传的那班全新的快车需要3小时55分钟。旧火车需要4小时20分钟。所以快了30分钟。是的。与此同时在东京。是的。是的。但我就在这里。我在，这栋楼叫什么名字？我在哈佛的保尔森工程学院，因为我周二和今天都在做客座讲座。然后周三，我和我的同事卡特里娜·里尔一起教授了一个Cuda Python教程。我玩得很开心，这里有很多非常棒、非常敏锐的学生。
leaves New York at 1130 p.m. and arrives at L.A. at like 3.30 a.m., which doesn't sound like fun. But I'm like, this is great. If I can get on this flight, then I can get to L.A., and then once I'm in L.A., I'll just figure something out. So that's exactly what I do. I get them to put me on the flight. I sleep on the six-hour flight. I get to L.A. at 3 a.m., and I call up the NVIDIA Corporate Travel Agency, and I'm like, hey, I'm in Los Angeles. Please find me a flight that will get me to San Francisco. by, you know, like 8 a.m. so that I can make this meeting. And they put me on a 630 flight and they got me there. But sadly, my mom couldn't come with me on the trip. But then this Monday, I was supposed to go to Boston. And, I'm sorry, yeah, on Monday I was supposed to go to Boston. On Saturday, they had already canceled my flight because there was this huge record-breaking Nor'easter that hit the New England area.
我没意识到这一点。真的吗？我没听说过哈佛有这个。不，我的意思是，这是一栋新建筑，一所新学院。那是开玩笑，布莱斯。那是开玩笑，布莱斯。这是常春藤盟校，世界上最好的学校之一。布莱斯在说，不，不，他们确实有一些聪明人在这里。
I don't think it was that bad. I grew up in Connecticut. We used to have a lot more. snow when I was a kid. But, you know, it was mostly just rain on Sunday. But anyways, they canceled my flight on Monday and they, like, rebooked me for a flight on, like, Tuesday that was, like, not great, but would have worked. But then, like, at that point, I was like, you know what, last time when the snowstorm was coming, I was just like, it'll be fine. My flight also will be able to make it out. And this time I planned ahead. So I went and I bought four fully refundable Amtrak tickets, one for Monday night and then like three for Tuesday morning, like at 5 a.m., 6 a.m. and 9 a.m. on Tuesday morning. And I figured like, you know, maybe they'll cancel my rebooked flight, which they did.
这是世界上最好的学校之一。但当你想到以高性能计算或计算机科学闻名的学校时，我认为哈佛可能不一定是首选。人们想到的是，你知道，也许哈佛法学院。当你想到哈佛以什么院系闻名时，你会想到什么？好吧，其实我会回答一个不同的问题。我的意思是，哈佛商学院绝对可能是第一。但当我想到顶尖计算机科学学校时，我的意思是，它不一定在前三名。就像，我想前三名对我来说，只是想到的，是麻省理工、斯坦福，然后可能是伯克利。
But there's no way that all four of these Amtraks are going to cancel. Well, by Monday night, my Monday Amtrak had canceled. And then like one of my trains on Tuesday had canceled. And so I went to sleep and then I woke up early trying, hoping to make this like 6, you know, 58. Amtrak to Boston. And then that canceled. And then the 9 a.m. one canceled. And then I was like, all right, I'm just going to take, I just took an Uber to Boston. Because I'm here.
但然后我不知道，卡内基梅隆也在那里。华盛顿大学。但我的意思是，哈佛，我，哈佛绝对应该在前十名。我知道这一点。对于计算机科学，好吧，也许我对此有偏见。但我会承认我。我的意思是，扎克伯格来自哈佛。一个人不能定义一所学校。
Just so the listener, the international listener knows, how long is a car ride, is an Uber from New York where you live to Boston? It's about, about three hours, three and a half hours. But here's the thing. Here's the thing. It was not that much more expensive than the price. of the train because the prices of the trains are crazy, like multiple hundreds of dollars, and the train takes like four hours. The train is slower than driving. The train is slower than driving. The train is slower than flying. And the fast train, you know, the brand new fast train that they just advertised takes like three hours and 55 minutes. The old train takes like four hours and 20 minutes. So it's like 30 minutes faster. Yeah. Meanwhile in Tokyo. Yeah. Yeah. But so here I am. I am at the, what's the name of this building? I'm at the Paulson School of Engineering at Harvard because I was doing a guest lecture on Tuesday and then also today. And then on Wednesday, I was teaching along with my colleague Katrina Real a Cuda Python tutorial. And I've been having great fun, really great, very sharp students here.
为了让听众，特别是国际听众了解一下，从你住的纽约坐优步到波士顿要多久？大概三到三个半小时吧。但重点是，重点是，它比火车票贵不了多少，因为火车票价简直离谱，要好几百美元，而且火车要坐四个小时。火车比开车还慢，比坐飞机也慢。他们刚宣传的那种所谓的高铁，也要三小时五十五分钟。老式火车要四小时二十分钟。所以也就快了三十分钟。是啊，反观东京那边。是啊。总之，我现在在，这栋楼叫什么来着？我在哈佛的保尔森工程学院，因为我周二和今天都要做客座讲座。周三的时候，我和同事卡特里娜·里尔一起教了一个Cuda Python教程。我玩得很开心，这里的学生真的很棒，非常聪明。
I did not realize that. Really? I haven't heard that about Harvard. No, I mean, this is a new building, a new school. That's a joke, Bryce. That's a joke, Bryce. This is Ivy League, one of the best schools in the world. Bryce is being like, no, no, they do have some bright people here.
我没意识到这一点。真的吗？我没听说过哈佛有这方面的情况。不，我是说，这是一栋新大楼，一所新学院。那是开玩笑的，布莱斯。那是开玩笑的，布莱斯。这是常春藤盟校，世界上最好的学校之一。布莱斯居然说，不，不，他们这里确实有一些聪明人。
It's one of the best schools in the world. But when you think of schools known for high performance computing or for like CS, I think Harvard is maybe not necessarily the top of mind. People think of like, you know, maybe Harvard. Law School. When you think of what what departments Harvard is known for, what comes to mind? Well, actually, I'll answer a different question. I mean, definitely HBS is probably the number one. But when I think of top CS schools, I mean, it's not necessarily in the top three. Like, I think the top three for me, like just that come to mine are MIT, Stanford and then probably Berkeley.
它是世界上最好的学校之一。但当你想到以高性能计算或计算机科学闻名的学校时，我觉得哈佛可能不一定是首选。人们想到的可能是，你知道，也许是哈佛法学院。当你想到哈佛以哪些院系闻名时，你会想到什么？嗯，其实我会回答一个不同的问题。我是说，哈佛商学院绝对可能是第一。但当我想到顶尖的计算机科学学校时，它不一定在前三名。比如，我心目中的前三名是麻省理工学院、斯坦福大学，然后可能是加州大学伯克利分校。
But then I don't know, Cardergy Melons up there. University of Washington. But I mean, Harvard, I, Harvard's definitely got to be in the top town. I know that. For CS, okay, maybe I'm on that. But, but I will admit that I. I mean, Zuckerberg's from Harvard. One person doesn't define a school.
但我不知道，卡内基梅隆大学也在那儿。华盛顿大学也是。但我的意思是，哈佛，哈佛绝对应该在前十名。我知道这一点。对于计算机科学，好吧，也许我在这方面有点偏见。但我承认，扎克伯格是哈佛出来的。一个人并不能定义一所学校。
I will readily admit that I may be wrong about CS in general. But for HBC in particular, super computing tends to be dominated by like large state schools historically. Like if you go to like a big supercomputing conference, you know, Yale, Princeton, Harvard, not going to have as big a presence as like the University of, you know, Illinois or, you know, the University of Texas or even, even like Louisiana State University, like these big, you know, publicly funded research universities. But yeah, no, the students here are very sharp doing all sorts of interesting research. The class that I'm giving a guest lectures for specifically in HBC class.
我愿意承认，我对计算机科学的总体看法可能是错的。但就高性能计算（HPC）而言，超级计算在历史上往往被大型州立大学所主导。比如，如果你去参加大型超级计算会议，你会发现耶鲁、普林斯顿、哈佛的参与度远不如伊利诺伊大学、德克萨斯大学，甚至路易斯安那州立大学这些大型公立研究型大学。不过，这里的学生确实非常敏锐，正在进行各种有趣的科研。我这次客座讲授的课程正是高性能计算课程。
A lot of the students have been interacting with are computational science doing scientists, doing, you're like from the physics department, who are just using computers to help them do their research better and faster. And yeah, I've been having a great time. I stand corrected. I stand corrected. Harvard on the US News, duck best graduate schools for computer science, comes in at number 19. And I think I got four of the top five, although now there's some ad that's blocking me and
我接触的许多学生都是从事计算科学的，他们来自物理系，只是利用计算机来帮助他们更好、更快地完成研究。是的，我过得很愉快。我收回前言，我收回前言。哈佛在《美国新闻与世界报道》的最佳计算机科学研究生院排名中位列第19。我想我找到了前五名中的四个，尽管现在有个广告挡住了我，
not able to read it. But I believe it was, yeah, MIT, Carnegie Mellon, Stanford, Berkeley, and then. urbanish campaign. I can't see the fifth one now because these ad blockers. And then also on CS rankings, which is a website that was initially built by Emery Berger, who has not been on the podcast. We really should have him on the podcast. We really should have him on the podcast. He's keynoted at different conferences and is a great speaker. We'll link a couple of his talks. Harvard comes in at number 40. And interesting, the top five, according to this site, and you can put a bunch of metrics, but just the default. I didn't click any buttons. It says Carnegie Mellon's number one,
没法读出来。但我相信是麻省理工、卡内基梅隆、斯坦福、伯克利，然后是厄巴纳-香槟分校。我现在看不到第五个，因为有广告拦截器。另外在CS Rankings上，这是一个最初由Emery Berger建立的网站，他还没上过我们的播客。我们真的应该邀请他上播客。我们真的应该邀请他上播客。他在不同的会议上做过主旨演讲，是一位出色的演讲者。我们会附上他的一些演讲链接。哈佛排名第40。有趣的是，根据这个网站，前五名是（你可以设置很多指标，但我用的是默认设置，没点任何按钮）：卡内基梅隆排名第一，
Urbana Champaign's number two, UCSD, University of California, San Diego is number three. Georgia Institute of Technology is number four? I would have never even... That makes sense. As somebody who looks at a lot of resumes, like, one, I know it's a, I know from my HBC days it was a big school, but also from somebody who looks at a lot of resumes, Georgia Institute of Tech comes across my desk a good bit. Interesting. Yeah. And then five is Berkeley. six is MIT and then seven Michigan and tied in eighth is Cornell and University of Washington. Anyways, I stand corrected. You were correct, though, number 19 on one side and number 40 on another site.
厄巴纳-香槟分校排名第二，加州大学圣地亚哥分校（UCSD）排名第三。佐治亚理工学院排名第四？我以前从来没想过……这倒说得通。作为一个看简历很多的人，一方面，我知道从我以前在高性能计算领域的日子来看，它是一所大校；另一方面，作为一个经常看简历的人，佐治亚理工学院的简历经常出现在我的桌上。很有趣。是的。然后第五名是伯克利，第六名是麻省理工，第七名是密歇根大学，第八名并列的是康奈尔大学和华盛顿大学。总之，我收回前言。不过你是对的，一个网站排第19，另一个排第40。
I guess I've over-indexed. I've got a biased view of Harvard because of Zuckerberg. So anyways, I think we've talked to on the podcast before a couple times about how I dropped out of college. I think we have talked also about how I did not have a good time in college in general. I did not enjoy being in classes. I did not enjoy being gritted on things. I felt like I always had this competitive relationship with just like the school system. And it was very frustrating for me. The only type of nightmares I still have, and I had one recently, the only type of nightmares I still have are nightmares about school. And usually the nightmare is that like, it's this persistent
我想我可能高估了哈佛，因为扎克伯格的缘故，我对哈佛有偏见。总之，我想我们在播客里已经聊过几次我大学辍学的事了。我想我们也聊过我大学生活总体过得并不愉快。我不喜欢上课，不喜欢被评分。我觉得我总是和学校体制处于一种竞争关系，这让我感到非常沮丧。我至今仍会做的唯一一种噩梦，我最近还做过一次，就是关于学校的噩梦。通常噩梦的内容是，这是一种持续的
nightmare. It's the only persistent dream I have. And it's that I had signed up for some class, but then basically had not shown up for the whole semester. And I'd thought it would not be a problem. but then like, you know, I learned that no, it's going to be a problem and that I'm going to fail this class. This is the only night, the only class of nightmare I've ever had has been about school. So it's been really the only thing that's given me a deep-seated anxiety. However, I was here at this brand new or this relatively new building that's across the river. It's in the Alaston part of Boston, which is not as like cool an area, but really nice building. And we went and had lunch in the first day.
噩梦。这是我唯一持续做的梦。梦见我选了一门课，但整个学期基本没去上过。我原以为这不会是个问题，但后来我发现，不，这会是个问题，我会挂科。这是我做过的唯一一种噩梦，都是关于学校的。所以这确实是我内心深处焦虑的唯一来源。不过，我当时是在河对岸那栋全新的或相对较新的大楼里。它位于波士顿的奥尔斯顿区，虽然那片区域没那么酷，但大楼真的很棒。第一天我们去那里吃了午饭。
And the little like the cafe nearby was very nice food. And the building's got all sorts of cool stuff. It was the first time I was like, hey, you know, this is actually a pretty nice school. And I thought to myself, I really should have applied myself more because I could have gone to school here. And this seems like it would have been fun. Well, haven't you been to the Stanford campus, haven't you? Stanford's gorgeous. I think I have been to Stanford.
附近的小咖啡馆食物很不错。大楼里有各种很酷的东西。这是我第一次觉得，嘿，这其实是一所很不错的学校。我心想，我真应该更努力一点，因为我本可以来这里上学的。这看起来会很有趣。好吧，你没去过斯坦福校园吗？斯坦福很漂亮。我想我去过斯坦福。
No, I think I have been to the Stanford campus. And no, I'll tell you, I'll tell you when I was at the Stanford campus. campus, Andrew Lumsdain, who was a boost person back in the day, professor at a bunch of different schools. I think now he's in the Northwest area. He was at Pacific, at the P&L lab, and I think also with a goodwill appointment at one of the universities up there. I want to say University of Washington, but I could be wrong. But anyways, a longtime colleague of mine, back to my days at LSU, he's one of the people behind the Boost Graph Library back in the day and did a bit of thing is on like the old, like, debate on modules, like, back in the history of C++. He was a little
不，我想我去过斯坦福校园。不，我告诉你，我告诉你我什么时候去过斯坦福校园。当时Andrew Lumsdain在场，他以前是Boost项目的成员，在多所学校担任教授。我想他现在在西北地区。他在太平洋西北国家实验室（P&L Lab），而且我想他在那里的一所大学也有客座职位。我想是华盛顿大学，但我可能记错了。总之，他是我的一位老同事，可以追溯到我在路易斯安那州立大学的日子。他是当年Boost图库的幕后功臣之一，在C++历史中关于模块的旧辩论中，他也有点
bit involved in that. And we worked together, collaborated a little bit on things relating to HPX. He gave a talk, I think, at some event at Stanford. And right after I'd moved to the Bay Area, I went to, this may have been when I was an intern at Berkeley Lab for a summer. I went to go see his talk. But I think that's the only time I've really been in the same for campus. I think I dropped a friend off there once too. But dude, you have to remember, I worked it, I worked at, I worked it at Berkeley lab and thus was technically an employee of UC Berkeley and, you know, Stanford, the arch, the arch enemy of UC Berkeley.
参与其中。我们一起工作过，在与HPX相关的事情上合作过。我想他在斯坦福的某个活动上做过演讲。就在我搬到湾区后不久，我去看了他的演讲。这可能是我在伯克利实验室实习的那个夏天。我想那是我唯一一次真正去过斯坦福校园。我想我也曾在那儿送过一个朋友。但伙计，你得记住，我在伯克利实验室工作过，因此从技术上讲是加州大学伯克利分校的员工，而你知道，斯坦福是加州大学伯克利分校的死对头。
It doesn't matter. I've been to Berkeley. I mean, I didn't attend either school, but I've been to Berkeley. Campus, talking about it. Yeah. No, no, no, I've been to Berkeley. Berkeley is not as beautiful as Stanford. No, no, no.
没关系。我去过伯克利。我是说，我两所学校都没上过，但我去过伯克利。校园，谈论它。是的。不，不，不，我去过伯克利。伯克利没有斯坦福那么漂亮。不，不，不。
I've been to both. Don't get me wrong. Berkeley is a beautiful campus, but it's kind of on the, the, the, the, his. hill. That's the part of the charm. I know, but it's kind of like the hill that could have a little bit more trees and like shrubbery to make it more green. So it's a little brown in the summer, whereas Stanford's always like immaculately
两所学校我都去过。别误会，伯克利是一个美丽的校园，但它有点建在……山上。那是它魅力的一部分。我知道，但它那座山要是能多点树木和灌木丛，让它看起来更绿一点就好了。所以夏天看起来有点发黄，而斯坦福总是修剪得
manicured. And like I used to bike there all the time. Well, this is, this is clearly just a plug for somebody at Stanford should invite Connor and I to go give a talk or something at Stanford so we can go walk together. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day.
非常整齐。我以前经常在那里骑车。好吧，这显然是在为斯坦福的某个人做广告，他们应该邀请康纳和我去斯坦福做个演讲什么的，这样我们就可以一起走走。请务必查看这些节目说明，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在ADSPthepodcast.com上，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个可以留下想法、评论和问题的GitHub讨论链接。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有愉快的一天。
Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
低质量，高产量。这就是我们播客的口号。那不是口号。我们的口号是“充满信息碎片的混乱”。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。